est ce que vous connaissez cet homme a
world in big fan
howard dean c'est l'histoire d'un
outsider qui est devenu une star du web
et de la démocratie
en 2004 lors des primaires américaines
il a été l'un des premiers à utiliser
les technologies pour rassembler et
mobiliser des communautés citoyenne à
l'époque l'époque des grands espoirs de
la démocratie numérique
son directeur de campagne joe trippi
avait écrit ce bouquin la révolution ne
sera pas télévisée a hélas plus de dix
ans passés et je crois que je peux
répondre à jo que la révolution n'a pas
été streamé non plus un exemple qui vous
parlera peut-être davantage
barack obama big big fan c'est la
personnalité la plus suivie sur les
réseaux sociaux pendant ses campagnes
présidentielles en 2008 et en 2012
il a récolté des millions de signatures
des millions d'e-mails des millions de
dollars et pourtant même avec ce super
swag numérique
barack obama n'a pas révolutionné la
démocratie et la politique non plus
alors si on regarde bien les mais aucune
nouvelle personnalité politique n'a
émergé dans le paysage les campagnes
électorales coûtent de plus en plus cher
les réseaux sociaux ont encore renforcé
l'hyper personnalisation du politique
est d'ailleurs un twitter reste utilisé
par une petite minorité hyper politisé
alors si la démocratie n'a pas été
révolutionnée c'est qu'elle est pas
facile a décrété par exemple en décembre
dernier 20 minutes a sorti ce sondage
qui dit que 74% des français pensent
qu'il aurait les meilleures idées que
nos élus ouais
alors est ce que cette bande de
révolutionnaires français monte vers
l'assemblée nationale et non alors en
même temps on est comprend si je vous
dis démocratie locale
ouais à un gymnase un préau d'école une
lumière jaune des néons trois pelés qui
discutent le coup sûr des abribus des
crottes de chiens je vous en veux pas
d'accord avec vous mais depuis que je
travaille pour la mairie de paris
je mets toute mon énergie faut que ça
change alors comme c'est le thème de la
journée
je suis venu vous présenter des
solutions de sortie de crise et pour
vous convaincre que l'innovation
politique est possible d'y représenter
l'exemple du budget participatif de la
ville de paris ouais si vous êtes des
voix de charente vous êtes un petit peu
familier avec le budget participatif
surtout si vous êtes allé au lycée dans
le conte le budget participatif le
concept c'est que la ville confie une
partie de son budget aux citoyens à
paris cette partie c'est 500 millions
d'euros un demi milliard un peu quoi
pour vous donner une idée à ce que ça a
changé dans le processus démocratique
autrefois jusqu'à aujourd'hui le budget
a été voté chaque année par le conseil
municipal
paris le conseil de paris chaque mois de
décembre de façon très solennelle et ça
représentait 163 conseillers de paris
qui prenait cette décision avec le
budget participatif
on est à plus de soixante six mille
personnes ce qui fait qu'on a x 410 le
nombre de décideurs politiques à paris
alors vous demandez quel rôle le
numérique joue dans cette multiplication
am3 fait d'abord tous les projets ont
été déposés en ligne ensuite les trois
quart des votants ont préféré voter sur
internet plutôt que de se rendre dans un
bureau de vote classique
enfin et là vous pouvez repensé à mon
prêt auto jaune la moyenne d'âge des
participants est descendu à 32 ans grâce
aux votes internet
alors pour être tout à fait transparente
avec vous puisque c'est mon credo d'un
même en multipliant par 410
je suis hyper fier de partager ce
résultat avec vous je pense que
n'importe quel dirigeant politique frère
à vide ces chiffres de participation
ça représente jamais que quelque chose
comme 2 % du corps électoral parisien la
révolution numérique ne se fait pas en
un clic
mais bonne nouvelle elle se fait en
profondeur
là encore pour affaires d'abord parce
que ce sont les citoyens qui propose les
projets un exemple en 2015 projet 54
renforcer l'aide aux personnes en
situation de précarité
c'est un projet qui a été déposée par
gunter barman et qui propose de
renforcer de renforcer le la rénovation
des bains douches des consignes des
bagagerie de paris pour améliorer
le quotidien des sans domicile fixe ce
projet ça a été l'un des trois projets
les plus votés de tout paris gros succès
est-ce que ce projet aurait vu le jour
sans gunther baumann
probablement pas est-ce que gunter
baumann murmure souvent à l'oreille des
élus n'ont jamais parce que gunter
barman et les sans domicile fixe et ce
projet à déposer en ligne
il est directement inspirée de son
expérience quotidienne dans les rues de
paris
deuxième exemple dans la façon de
réaliser les projets en 2014
les parisiens ont voté massivement
massivement pour la végétalisation de
paris on leur a proposé d'aller plus
loin avec leur smartphone
on leur a demandé d'identifier dans les
rues de paris en bas de chez eux les
murs vides
inutilisé qui pourraient devenir des
forêts végétales ces partis déjà 200
murs végétalisés de façon participative
depuis le début de l'année et si vous
promener dans paris
vous pourrez voir des plaques décidée
par les parisiens et ça fait chaud au
coeur
troisième révolution ma préférée la
révolution dans la culture de
l'administration oui aux 66 mille
votants
il faut que vous ajoutiez à peu près la
même somme soixante mille agents de la
ville de paris qui expérimente en ce
moment même les joies de l'intelligence
collective avec vous vous imaginez ils
ont reçu 5000 projet beaucoup plus que
dans le cours d'une année normale
maintenant il faut qu'ils les expertises
qui discute avec les parisiens
ils sont tenus de poster leur expertise
en ligne transparence oblige
et maintenant ils vont devoir les mettre
en oeuvre en ayant sur vidéo
les auteurs très exigeant normal alors
voilà on aurait pu faire appel à un
cabinet de consulting qui aurait fait de
l'audi des entretiens il aurait proposé
un plan de restructuration mais voilà je
recommande à tous les responsables qui
sont dans la salle le budget
participatif comme programme
d'accompagnement au changement
super et ce set
le tueur de l'innovation politique elle
dépasse maintenant les murs de paris il
ya un milan et rome qui sont entrés en
contact avec nous pour lancer leurs
propres budgets participatifs madrid a
lancé une plate-forme qui fait appel à
la créativité des citoyens pour trouver
des nouveaux projets urbains et puis à
grenoble qui vient de finir son premier
cycle i à rennes qui vient de se lancer
peut-être la rochelle bientôt en tout
cas moi ça alimente vraiment ma
conviction que l'innovation politique
elle se fait en local je pense que il
suffit d'une personne dans une réunion
une personne dans un conseil
d'administration une personne dans un
conseil municipal pour introduire une
idées destructives
mais pour ça j'ai besoin de vous je peux
pas y arriver tout seul j'ai besoin de
vous pour entrer en contact avec les 74%
de parisiens dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
74 60 français qui pensent que leur voix
ne sera pas prise en compte que la
participation ça sert à rien j'ai besoin
de vous pour que vous passiez le mot
interpellé veau et lui demander des
comptes
réclamer la transparence réclamée des
outils qui le permettent et je vous
propose même si vous voulez de commencer
tout de suite avec la rochelle et pour
vous mâcher un petit peu le travail
j'ai préparé une mission alors je vous
propose d'envoyer un tweet au maire de
la rochelle à quand le budget
participatif à la rochelle c'est hyper
simple vous mettez son acte le hashtag
du ted et je vous garantis que si reçoit
dans les dix minutes qui viennent
300 tweets il va comprendre qu'il se
passe un truc dans cette salle
je viens je j'en vois qui sortent d'un
téléphone portable c'est chouette
et voilà ce sera peut-être le début
d'une mini révolution numérique puisque
je vous le rappelle elle n'a toujours
pas eu lieu alors faites le
merci beaucoup
d